love death and robots brings a wealth of
outstanding stories and fascinating
episodes from the minds of Tim Miller
David Fincher and many more there are 18
in total and after binge watching them
all twice I decided to put together a
list of my top five episodes from the
show to let you know which ones are
worth checking out there are lots of
spoilers here in regards to the plots of
the episode so if you don't want to know
anything at all then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way
I'm definition and let's get into my
list of the top five love death and
robots episodes number one Sony's edge
Sony's edge kicks off the series in
outstanding fashion with a look at a
futuristic London underworld that sees
beasts fight in arenas for cash prizes
whilst this could be your
run-of-the-mill rocky esque story
there's a deeper level to this with the
titular character Sonny being alpha
revenge against those who gang raped her
the ending is a phenomenal twist and the
gore nudity and violence from the off
let you know exactly what you in for
with the series I could happily watch
hours of this and that's why it ranks in
the top five for me
number two suits suit is one of the most
distinctive episodes animation wise and
it's also a blast from start to finish
the episode centers around a community
of farmers that use their homemade mechs
to defend the planet from what appears
to be an alien invasion sprinkled
through our references to acquire place
signs aliens and more and the piece
feels like a horror sci-fi masterpiece
there's a phenomenal twist at the end
that lets you know maybe these guys
aren't necessarily the ones that we
should be rooting for but overall it's a
phenomenal episode number three when the
yoghurt took over when the yoghurt took
over is one of the shortest episodes
from the series but it also is one of
the funniest in concept alone this is
amazing and the ideas presented
throughout it are hilarious basically
after scientists accidentally breed a
super intelligent yogurt it slowly takes
over the world before travelling into
space because even though it wants
what's best for Humanity we are too vain
to follow it
this is a masterpiece and the short
boots we ever sewed should definitely be
a go-to for when you're looking for
things to watch from the season
it's brilliant from beginning to end and
definitely secures a much deserved spot
here number four shapeshifters
shapeshifters is quite similar to the
Dracula episode in some respects but I
feel that it goes above and beyond in
many ways it follows a group of enhanced
humans known as dog soldiers as they
fight in the Middle East and it not only
works as a brilliant metaphor for the
Iraq war but also as the u.s. in general
the country is happy to have these
people fight for them but that doesn't
mean they view them as equals even
though they deserve to be this metaphor
for racism is mixed in so well with the
heart racing action transformation
scenes and some of the best CGI in the
series to bring an episode that feels
like it should be if be chill and film
this is gray and is a must watch for
anyone looking to get into the show
number five Ice Age Ice Age stars Topher
Grace and Mary Elizabeth Winstead and
instantly it feels like one of the
biggest events of the series after they
find a lost civilization inside an
antique freezer that is left in their
new apartment they watched the future of
humanity play out in front of them first
as a woolly mammoth found in an ice cube
and from here it evolves into
intergalactic travel remember when Lisa
managed to build a microscopic universe
in the Simpsons well imagine that with a
bigger budget inexpertly shows just how
far we've come as people and how far we
have to go and that's why it's one of
the best episodes in the run
obviously I'd love to hear your top 5
episodes and if you agree with mine
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of Sony's edge and my review
of the series as a whole which would be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]